this week on the climate show we're
delving into our brains looking at the
psychology of climate change and asking
why it is we find it so difficult to get
off the couch and do something about it
preferring just to slump back and let
the messages of Doom wash over us
[Music]
hello I'm Tom Heap and welcome to the
show in a week when the United Nations
released a comprehensive scientific
report offering Humanity a final warning
to avert climate catastrophe why is it
we find these Bleak but urgent messages
so easy to ignore also on the show we
take you to Vanuatu the Pacific island
already being battered by worsening
climate events they hope a un vote next
week will provide the chance to hold
polluting Nations to account
[Music]
I hear about the Flight of the Osprey
Expedition as one woman attempts to make
an epic 10 000 kilometer journey to
highlight how climate change risks one
iconic species
and as the clocks spring forward this
weekend are the changing seasons
themselves shifting
but first ticking Time Bomb final
warning for Humanity we've heard some
pretty dire predictions this week but
does this kind of language just turn
people off I've been looking at how our
brains deal with climate change
humanity is on thin ice and that ice is
melting fast the the world has suffered
greatly from ongoing climate change we
can't afford any time to be lost These
Warnings all follow this week's critical
report from the United Nations on the
causes effects and solutions to climate
change they hit hard
so how come that message that the end of
the world could be now it doesn't get
through to our thick skulls how come
we're not animated into taking urgent
action rather than continuing pretty
much as usual thanks
I've taken a trip to the psychologists
to find out if you frame things in a way
that scares people uh it might lead to
disengagement and people might tune out
because they feel too overwhelmed to
want to take action and so that leads to
maladaptive behaviors like disengagement
denial tuning out feeling overwhelmed
and worry on the other hand
can be a motivator we want people to be
appropriately worried uh and motivated
to take corrective action not scare to
the point where they're just going to
run away and hide so to speak one of the
UN reports authors Freddy Otto has seen
that firsthand I think people are really
people I talk to are really scared
there's a lot of
um because are they scared into action
no they are not scared into action and I
think that's a problem because we have
um reporting about
the threat and the the with the very
Doom and Gloom and if you think you're
Doom you could well it's too late to act
and that's just not true we decided to
test out some of the phrases about
climate change that sander the
psychologist thought might get
interesting reactions experts agree it's
real it's us it's bad but there's hope
and so this message signals to people
that it's a serious issue but that
there's hope and so it ends on a
positive note climate change is going to
destroy Humanity within the next Century
I mean this is a very scary uh scenario
and that I would predict that people
typically tune out from that and
disengage more and more people are
changing their behavior to address
climate change well these are the
statements that sand Evander Linden
recommended we try out on the public I'm
in Piccadilly Circus who's my first
catch
according to each statement does it make
you feel engaged at one end or
disengaged at the other so the first one
with regards climate change experts
agree it's real it's us it's bad but
there is hope does that leave you
feeling engaged or disengaged on that
scale where would you pin your first
brain
um
engage okay this one is slightly more
Doom Laden if you like does that leave
you feeling engaged or disengaged
[Music]
okay
and the last one which is about other
people are changing their behavior would
that kind of encourage you as well oh
definitely yeah
so what is the experiment shown well
this is human psychology so it never
quite goes according to the script but
there are some Trends here the top one
about expert opinions that does seem to
engage people there's a real cluster of
five or six up here at the engaged end
the more Doom Laden one
although there is some spread there are
more down at the disengaged Zen there
are five down here some in the middle
and one yeah that did really engage them
as to the more herd mentality one a
pretty even spread but for one
sustainability influencer social
pressures did kick her into action I was
actually called out on social media so I
was sharing my plant-based Lifestyle on
YouTube and someone said great that
you're eating vegetables but you're
wearing fast fashion and that doesn't
really align
um and so that was the moment where I
thought oh I kind of felt a bit taken a
bath back at first and then I went away
watching book mentories read some books
and here we are and what would you say
to others or maybe your followers indeed
who are watching this what do you think
would get them to change their behavior
in a more climate friendly Direction I
think it's that their decisions and
actions matter it's an invitation to say
hey Carmen join us we're having a great
time and we're actually making a
difference
well how are people receiving these
climate change messages of course via
the media broadcast or indeed Prince I'm
having a little paper review here with
Tom Walker AKA comedian Jonathan pie
um
Tom I mean we look at the papers here
that came out on Tuesday the day after
this these dire warnings didn't make
lead story on any of them as far as we
can see not really you've got climate
catastrophe imminent says un on page 19.
let's give them their due you've got uh
you know Putin meeting uh the Chinese
president you've got Westminster Going
Bonkers this week you've got the Met
police being found to be you know all
sorts of horrible things so it's not
been you know it's it's kind of
understandable that a lot of the pages
are full of other stuff
[Music]
Jonathan pie released a new video this
week translating climate science
Imagine That by some incredible Miracle
we can still save ourselves but you can
present some very very tough difficult
issues and if you can make people laugh
they're more likely listen to listen to
the serious bit afterwards if someone
can watch something that I do about the
environment it changes their mind gets
them to write to their MP gets them to
get marching and gets them proactive
then I think that's something that I can
do and I'm glad to do that you know
Freddie the climate scientist has one
message she wants to get across the most
important message is that we have all
the knowledge all the tools all the
technology we need to keep the climate
from warming more than 1.5 degrees we
have an important job to do to make life
better for for everyone
but we can do it
so how bad are things and is there a
narrative of hope to be found here's our
science editor Tom Clark to break it all
down for us this is the sixth report
from the ipcc and in the 20 years I've
been covering climate each has said
broadly the same thing we have to act
now on climate change time is running
out but we have the solutions the
difference is in each report the science
has become more certain the Call's more
urgent the time to act ever shorter what
makes this one stand out is it's likely
to be the last warning we have before
it's too late to avoid 1.5 degrees take
a look at their modeling and you can see
why what we're seeing in the red line
are current policies and targets the
Blue Line shows the dramatic cuts that
we need that need to happen if we're
going to stay within 1.5 degrees of
warming a Target that will slip within
the next decade the report finds in less
Global carbon emissions are cut in half
by 2030 and to near Zero by 2050. so
what does that look like in real terms
well it looks like this the darkening
colors show the percentage of species
threatened with Extinction at different
levels of warming one and a half degrees
the worst impacts are confined to the
tropics but above two there are
significant threats to species including
large amounts of marine life globally
and there's of course an impact on human
health too Rising heat and humidity will
increase the number of days and the
range of locations where heat stroke is
a concern and many people will need
access to artificial cooling just to
survive
one of the most striking quotes in the
report says there is a rapidly closing
window of opportunity to secure a
livable and sustainable future for all
the choices and actions implemented in
this decade will have impacts now and
for thousands of years but the report
according to the U.N Secretary General
is best viewed as a guide to what those
actions should be
we have never been better equipped to
solve the climate challenge but we must
move into warp speed climate action now
we don't have a moment to lose many of
the tools to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions are right here in front of us
Technologies like renewable energy green
buildings and electric vehicles but also
protecting forests and wetlands and
oceans to absorb more carbon and
adapting agriculture as well as our
diets but on current trends we are
looking at more than one and a half
degrees of warming in the coming decades
and we're not doing enough to adapt
especially as the report warns the
longer we wait the harder adapting
becomes adaptation options that are
feasible and effective today will become
constrained and less effective with
increasing global warming it says with
increasing global warming losses and
damages will increase additional human
and natural systems will reach
adaptation limits main taken from that
is the longer we delay the more costly
and difficult adapting becomes and with
it the risks of things going very wrong
the war in Ukraine the small boat
migrant crisis Rising inflation were
stories that kept this week's warning
from the scientists off newspapers front
pages but conflict food and energy in
security migration they're just the
sorts of things that are becoming more
likely as we allow the warming Trend to
continue
a country on the front line when it
comes to climate change is the Pacific
island of Vanuatu that has recently
suffered from two category four Cyclones
it comes just as the United Nations
General Assembly is about to vote on
whether the international court of
justice should be able to apply legal
consequences for those who cause the
climate change in the first place
Sephora Smith reports
as the UN warns there is a rapidly
closing window to secure a livable
future for all the Pacific island nation
of Vanuatu is already under assault from
extreme weather
it was ferocious
never been experienced such anger in the
Wind
it held and it was
just unimaginable I was in fear
category 4 Cyclones Judy and Kevin tore
through homes cut electricity and
wrecked livelihoods affecting the vast
majority of the 320 000 people living in
this country
housewife Karen Patricia lost her
kitchen in the flooding caused by the
storms
so the wind came and the flood came the
flood take my kitchen and put on the
other side of the road my properties
were there
so now I have no kitchen I just cook
beside my house and my property everyone
was gone like plate cap spoon everything
scientists say climate change has
increased the occurrence of the most
intense and destructive storms but this
country is putting up a fight
the government of Vanuatu is leading a
call for the international court of
justice to clarify the obligations of
states to tackle climate change and the
consequences of failing to do so under
international law
The Proposal is expected to be put to a
vote at the UN next week with more than
a hundred of the 193 U.N Nations
publicly supporting the initiative
many here support government efforts to
Galvanize Global action against climate
change and say they feel let down by the
inaction of industrialized nations I
would I would like to see someone
contribute some admission of
accountability by developed countries
it's important for Vanuatu to take this
message our government to the world and
to make sure that other countries have
around the world have the respect for
other people regardless of where they're
living
it must be extraordinary to live in a
country quite so vulnerable to some of
the most immediate effects of climate
change now after the break we'll be
going on a more than 6 000 mile Trek to
follow one of our most iconic migratory
Birds the Osprey to see if its movements
are becoming vulnerable to climate
change and also We'll be asking despite
this rather cold and wet spring how is
our spring overall responding to climate
change
thank you
welcome back to the show now at this
time of year some of our most majestic
migratory birds are making their way
back to Britain from their winter homes
in West Africa just this week a breeding
pair of Ospreys returned to the lock of
lows in perthshire just six hours apart
something that the Scottish Wildlife
trust says has never happened before
the female arrived back first started
pimping up the nest and lo and behold
exactly six hours later her mate lm12
landed on the nest and they quickly
became reacquainted and he was showing
off in the sky doing a sky dance for her
and Julie came in with a fish to seal
their bond
I love those pictures especially the one
of the Osprey couple it looks like
they're saying to each other how was
your journey dear as if they've just
come in from work
osprey's history has been a slightly
checkered one good of late they're
returning to a number of locks and lakes
but previous to that they almost became
extinct in this country thanks to egg
theft and other forms of persecution
their threat now is mainly from climate
change especially on their long
migratory route from West Africa their
epic route takes them from Guinea on the
west of that continent all the way up to
Scotland and other places in England as
well and they face plenty of challenges
along the way not least storms and the
Sahara Desert
and now I'm about to join someone who'll
be accompanying them on their journey
and that's Sasha Dench who's an
adventurer and real Enthusiast for
migratory birds and she is in Guinea
Sasha very good to see you uh tell me
exactly what are you going to be doing
on your journey and what do you hope to
find out
so we've been concerned for some time
about the Ospreys obviously an
incredible effort has been put in in
Scotland and across the UK and in fact
across Europe to reintroduce the birds
where they had disappeared but now we're
still facing a situation where about
somewhere between 60 and 70 percent of
young birds don't return and so we're
really interested to find out more about
that so in order to do that we figured
the best possible way to do that was to
explore their entire migration range all
the way between the UK and Europe and
West Africa so we're going to be doing
the journey hopefully learning from
locals all along the Route hearing from
them any threats they see the Ospreys
facing and we're also trying to look at
some of the bigger issues faced by the
birds and how will you yourself be
traveling
so we will be traveling in a Land Rover
there's four of us going to be probably
behind you yeah there was a clue behind
us it's actually got a uh a pop top as
well in it and um then so we'll be going
mostly by land so that we can meet with
people some of the key issues we're on
aerial view will give us an important
Insight uh we'll be do it using drones
what could be the threats regarding
climate change for these birds for
example more extreme weather conditions
so many of the juvenile Birds because
lots of them well they've basically come
from European northern European
populations
um most of the young birds unfortunately
think they are coming from Europe when
they do their first migration on their
own so they try to take a much more
Westerly route and they end up on the
tip of Cornwall trying to figure out
what's the shortest route to the next
bit of land South and many of them got
blown offshore so we've already had two
of our young birds disappear um or one
of them certainly two of them disappear
one of them definitely um lost to out to
the Sea they also have the vast expanse
of the Sahara to cross and the Sahara is
getting bigger but also the weather
conditions more extreme there's also
some unintended consequences
unfortunately for us so we're obviously
we need more renewable energy wherever
you build renewable energy there's also
the power line infrastructure that's
needed and that is causing a problem for
many birds if the if they aren't
constructed in the right way
well we'll be checking in with you over
the coming weeks just briefly what kind
of things might we expect to learn the
first thing that we're going to be going
to do is trying to find a beloved bird
called 4K who was tagged at Rutland
water years ago he's now been connected
with a local community in the mangrove
forests of Guinea who um have renamed
the bird they thought 4K was a
ridiculous unfriendly name they call him
Dobby Ray we'll go and find out if he is
still where he where he was before his
tag has stopped working on the way back
we're going to try and find a juvenile
bird called Glenn who's already had an
incredible Venture he uh hitched a ride
on two container ships on the way to get
here it was considered missing twice
even a police search was sent out for
him but he's decided to stop his
migration in the middle of the Sahara
and not go go forward so we're going to
figure out is this if this could be a
new strategy uh for Birds but we're also
going to go and see sites where uh we
know that the key habit some of the key
habitats they're using are um are
disappearing and figure out why thanks
Sasha and good luck well an amazing
journey can't wait to see how they get
on now the clocks are springing forward
this weekend and the signs of a changing
season are all around us but is climate
change bringing things even further
forward we've been finding out
foreign
develops tree after tree and shrub after
shrub will come into flower
[Music]
when I started gardening you wouldn't
plant anything out in the open ground
until late May or early June because the
risk of frost was so great nowadays the
frost pretty well evaporates by the end
of April
this is a lucosium or snowflake it's
little snowdrop-like flowers are very
attractive at this season when the snow
drops are over
you were to ask a meteorologist they
would say that spring is between March
April and May but of course nature
doesn't follow our rules it follows its
own rules and so season Creek really is
when we're starting to see things out of
season so an example this year is that
we saw flowering Hazel flowering
snowdrops and Budge burst in Elder
Before Christmas
[Music]
oh
everything in Spring once plants have
had their winter chilling is directly
dependent on the temperature and as the
temperature rises things grow faster but
there's more to it than that plants are
integrating mechanisms so they sort of
sum up and take an average of the
temperature over the period so even
though there may be fewer Frost and less
intense frosts the plants are growing
much more narrow than they used to
[Music]
there was a gentleman called Robert
Marshall who started recording what he
called his indications of spring
in Norfolk in 1736 and we still have his
records and they formed part of the
historic basis of the Nature's calendar
records which is members of the public
recording uh signs of the seasons as
they change
[Music]
and will be on air over the weekend at
three o'clock and 7 P.M on Saturday and
Sunday or you can catch up anytime
online see you next week
foreign